When we make a map, we are trying to convey
some information about a part of the real
world.
But every part of the world contains far more
detail than we could ever convey easily on
a map, not least because maps always show
the world at a smaller scale than it really
is.
The infinite detail of the real world means
that it can sometimes be challenging to manage
all the data we want to include on a map.
In fact, to make any map we have to simplify
the real world.
One way to do that is to think of the world
as being made up of different types of features.
A feature could be something from the physical
world, such as the outline of a building,
the course of a street, or the location of
a tree.
A feature could also be a an event that happened
in a particular place, such as the location
of an individual crime.
There are infinite types of features that
we could put on maps, but computers typically
store individual features in three different
ways: as points, as lines or as polygons.
Points are used to represent physical features
such as street lights, as well as the locations
of individual events.
Lines are used to represent physical features
such as walls and roads, as well as behavioural
features such as routes from one place to
another.
Polygons are used to represent features like
the outline of a building or the area covered
by a police force.
Most files that store spatial information
can only store points, lines or polygons – not
a mixture of different types.
That means it’s usual for information about
different types of feature to be stored in
different files.
For example, if we wanted to find the nearest
police station to a set of crime locations,
we would probably have a dataset of police
station locations and a separate dataset of
crime locations.
Once we have all the data we need, we can
build a map by adding each type of feature
as a separate map layer.
Every map is made up of multiple layers of
data, stacked on top of one another.
For example, we might have a layer representing
roads, another representing buildings, and
so on.
It can be easy to end up trying to show a
lot of data on a map, either because the map
shows a large area or because it shows a lot
of detail.
Eventually the amount of data becomes hard
to work with.
If that happens we can simplify the data by
converting the points, lines or polygons on
the map into a raster layer.
A raster layer is made up of a grid of cells
– sometimes called pixels – with each
cell having a single value associated with
it.
In this course we will see several examples
of raster layers on maps.
The first are called base maps, which show
all the different physical features in an
environment as a single layer.
Base maps like this one can be very useful
because they mean we don’t have to deal
with separate layers for every type of feature
we want to show on a map.
But because we can’t access each feature
individually, we cannot easily choose what
information is shown on a base map, or how
features are represented.
That means it’s important to choose a base
map that shows the information we need in
a clear way.
Fortunately, there are lots of useful base
maps available online.
To summarise:
Spatial data can be represent as points, lines
or polygons
We can build maps by stacking layers of features
on top of each other
We can represent features as rasters to make
them easier to work with